Nancy Pelosi who is by my last count 584
years old she is running for
reelection Nancy tweeted Out quote our
city needs us to advance San Francisco
values and further our country yeah yeah
we we need drug addled bums defecating
on the street from Sea to shining sea
our country needs America to show the
world that our flag is still there it's
a rainbow flag by the way it's not the
red white and blue they got rid of that
one but the rainbow flag is still there
with liberty and justice for all that's
why I'm running for re-election and
respectfully ask for your vote Nancy I
don't mind that she's running for
re-election it's not good it's bad but I
kind of get a kick out of some of these
olders who have been these women of a
certain age and some of the Oldtimer
male politicians who have been around
forever Bernie you know all of them
they're going to hold on as long as they
can the people are allowing them to hold
on okay that's just how politics works